bonsoir nous sommes le lundi 12
septembre merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
on commence tout de suite avec les
titres
le président françois hollande
accompagné de la ministre du travail mme
myriam el khomri aujourd'hui à saint
quentin en yvelines objets de leur
visite les locaux de l'institut de
formation commerciale permanente il faut
que coop à montigny le bretonneux
l'occasion de faire un point d'étape sur
le plan 500000 informations
supplémentaires annoncée en janvier par
le chef de l'état nous y reviendrons et
l'aïd el-kébir la plus grande fête de la
communauté musulmane débute ce lundi si
nous sommes allés à la rencontre des
fidèles à l'abattoir mowgli de trappes
le cinq du département et enfin point
sur la météo l'été continue pour le
plaisir de tous mais attention cela ne
va peut être pas durer
et on ouvre ce journal avec bien sûr la
venue de françois hollande le président
de la république était en déplacement
cet après midi à saint quentin en
yvelines voulez vous voyez sur ces
quelques images car la prise de vidéos a
été restreinte il était accompagné de
myriam el khomri la ministre du travail
s'est rendue à l'institut de formation
commerciale permanent pour évoquer
notamment la mise en place du plan 500
formations supplémentaires un plan qui a
été lancé en janvier et qui a pour
objectif de favoriser l'embauché des
chômeurs longue durée et peu qualifiés
depuis son annonce plus de 400 personnes
ont pu bénéficier d'une formation le
plan gouvernemental prévoit d'atteindre
la barre du million d'ici le 31 décembre
prochain
et des musulmans débute aujourd'hui la
célébration de l'aïd el kébir pour
l'amener à 2016 c'est l'une des fêtes
les plus importantes de l'islam cette
célébration commémore le sacrifice
avortée du fils d'ibrahim à son dieu
attrape l'abattoir mobile a de nouveau
été mis en place pour l'occasion de
nombreux fidèles ont fait le déplacement
car c'est le seul du département osman
un vendeur d et nicolas d'entrée pour ce
reportage
à suivre le sens
à l'occasion de la fête de l'aïd
el-kébir l'abattoir mobile était de
retour ce matin venu chanter rando
attrape une foule de fidèles étaient
réunis devant l'abattoir installé par la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines mille quatre
cents moutons seront vendus aux fidèles
et pour cette journée qui s'annonce
rythmée l'organisation a fait appel à
des bouchers venus du royaume uni le
travail dans des abattoirs qui peuvent
monter jusqu'à 300 à l'heure de cadence
là nous faisons sans agneaux tous les
une heure et quart une toutes les
soixante cinq minutes il ya ce sens
agneaux qui sortent en bout de chaîne
mais pour ça il faut c'est une cadence
infernale il n'y a quasiment personne en
abattoir en abattoirs en france qui est
capable de sortir ça c'est pour ça que
nous faisons appel à ce personnel qui a
vraiment qui est vraiment sûr qualifier
et pour la première fois cette année une
journée de vente privée été mise en
place mercredi dernier le but permettre
aux musulmans de l'agglomération de
choisir leurs moutons en avance une
organisation qui ravit les consommateurs
très très satisfait parce qu'elle est
déjà à côté de chez moi je tape à des
kilomètres et kilomètres avec des
vétérinaires qui contrôle tout ça et je
mange des croquis sur jaurès connaît des
malades et n'est rien c'est bon pour moi
pour moi personnellement c'est très très
satisfaisant on apprend à l'heure où ils
ont annoncé
c'est bien organisé à l'intérieur
les fidèles peuvent encore choisir leurs
moutons demain sur place ou via internet
l'abattoir mobile est ouvert de 8h30 à
19h30 avenue jean théron beaux attrapés
on va parler à mme était à présent vous
avez certainement à profiter du beau
temps aujourd'hui 30 degrés à paris cet
après midi 33 degrés demain la rentrée
de ce mois de septembre 2016 vague de
chaleur cette période chaude est elle
exceptionnelle en tout cas ce n'est pas
pour déplaire à certains les
explications avec corinne salon
vanessa est étudiante en master
enseignement
voilà tout juste une semaine qu'elle a
repris des cours et cette année la
rentrée c'est aussi des bains de soleil
dans le parc de l'université
mi-septembre très agréable il fait 30
degrés on reprend les cours en douceur
il fait beau l'été se prolonge donc
c'est vraiment très agréable
eleanor et anglaise et travaille à paris
aujourd'hui elle profite du temps
estival pour se détendre dans le pack de
50 ans aujourd'hui jeu parfait d'une
journée
devaux et
je profite du soleil je sais qu'il est
un parc lycée il ya de l'eau et c'est
agréable pour le prévisionniste météo
jean-françois doug et ses températures
n'ont rien d'étonnant pour un début de
mois de septembre en 1947 on a eu aussi
des fortes températures en 2003
également on a eu 30 degrés
en septembre finalement c'est assez
fréquent d'avoir des températures qui
dépassent et 30 degrés au moins début
septembre quoi profiter du beau temps et
des parcs ensoleillé car cette vague de
chaleur va bientôt s'interrompre avec le
retour de la pluie prévue pour mercredi
et reprenons la direction de trappes
retour sur le forum à des associations
comme chaque année de nombreuses
familles se sont rendues à l'événement
qui s'est déroulé ce samedi à 10
septembre alors parmi des figures
historiques comme le club de basket de
nouvelles associations étaient présentes
regardez son et image signée patrick
jacques de dixmude un
forum des associations rime souvent avec
affluence au complexe sportif brouste à
la trappe pour l'association escaladent
ce forum est une première
créé en 2013 elle prévient et prend en
charge le décrochage scolaire chez des
enfants et adolescents de 5 à 25 ans
elle accompagne également les familles
et les professionnels en difficulté dans
ce domaine nous propose une permanence
fixe dans les collèges et à partir de là
on essaie de les accompagner de manière
très régulière en moyenne une fois
toutes les deux semaines pour pour la
plupart mais ça peut être plus fréquents
voire moins fréquents s'ils ont moins
besoin d'accompagnement
l'association intervient dans les
collèges de village youri gagarine
gustave courbet à trappes et alexandre
dumas à maurepas pour l'instant elle
cherche de la visibilité car elle a
encore besoin de se faire connaître
contrairement à d'autres comme l'étoile
des cheminots de trappes né en 1937 le
club de basket ne rate jamais un forum
ça vous permet d'avoir de nouvelles
familles de nouvelles personnes des
nouveaux jeunes on a des habitués qui
sont là depuis plus de disons club et
c'est vrai que renouveler un peu les
nouvelles générations et leur permet de
pratiquer le basket c'est très important
pour nous l'année dernière le club
totalise et 230 licenciés il espère
faire mieux cette année grâce à l'
influence positive de l'équipe de france
masculine mais aussi féminine lors des
jeux de rio 2016
une nouvelle initiative la mise en place
à part la ville de montigny le
bretonneux à l'organiser dans la matinée
du vendredi 9 septembre une session de
recrutement pour deux dispositifs des
devoirs l'étude surveillée et d'études
dirigé une quinzaine de candidats
étaient reçus majoritairement des
étudiants mais aussi des adultes en
recherche d'emploi ces missions se
déroulent trois jours dans la semaine le
lundi le mardi et le jeudi de 17 heures
à 18 heures avec des groupes d'élèves
pour un salaire compris entre 21 et 23
euros de l'heure la directrice de la
maison de quartier louis jouvet de monti
le bretonneux monde 2006 le bretonneux
pardon à nos réalités est revenu en
détails sur ce dispositif écoutez là
on est soit sur une mission de
surveillance et d'aménagement de mettre
les jeunes dans de bonnes conditions
pour la réussite scolaire et sur l'étude
dirigée on a vraiment un rôle
pédagogique de renforts au niveau des
apprentissages de
pouvoir amener aussi une organisation
une méthodologie au niveau d'un public
cette fois-ci collégiens et parlons à
présent voiture et nîmes et solidarité
c'est dimanche le lion's-club
d'elancourt a organisé son premier
rallye automobile une dizaine de
voitures sont parties de but pour
rejoindre l'ancienne mairie des noms
courts en traversant la vallée de la
bièvre l'argent récolté servira à
financer le don d'un chien d'assistance
pour personnes handicapées camille
lambert et patrick jacques de dixmude à
anneaux c'est une première pour sylvain
dimanche 11 septembre les apprentis
enquêteurs récolte des indices avec sa
famille il participe au rallye surprise
organisé par le lion's club d'elancourt
au profit de l'association handi'chiens
c'est l'ambiance et apprendre des choses
et puis passer un bon moment voilà plus
en plus
avec des énigmes à résoudre en équipe
les 40 participants découvrent la vallée
de la bièvre et ses curiosités
différentes étapes ponctuent le parcours
jusqu'à l'ancienne mairie d'elancourt un
moyen de s'amuser tout en faisant une
bonne action qu'il s'agit de financer le
don d'un chien à on a choisi un jeune
handicapé en a pas je peux pas vous dire
encore six étages malvoyants un autiste
mais c'est ce type de profil que l'on
vise également les schizophrènes pour
lesquelles l'utilisation du cheval est
très importante c'est au delà du chien
guide d'aveuglé là on est plutôt sur des
personnes avec un handicap moteur et le
chien peut accomplir des petites tâches
comme ouvrir une porte ouvrir le frigo
pour aider les personnes cette
manifestation a permis de récolter
environ 600 euros un chien d'assistance
coûte 15000 euros il faut en moyenne
trois ans au club pour recueillir les
fonds nécessaires à ce type d'opération
d'autres aux événements solidaires sont
organisées toute l'année
et on ouvre à présent une page sports en
golf le pari legend championship et est
organisé pour la première fois sur les
greens du golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines sté ce week-end plus une
cinquantaine de légende de la discipline
se sont affrontés pendant trois jours
sous la chaleur comme vous le voyez sur
ces images autour d'une carte de 69
magnus pie hat les villes remporté la
compétition avec un bilan de - 8 sur
l'albatros le suédois signe au passage
sa première victoire sur le seigneur
taux européens rendez vous l'année
prochaine pour la deuxième édition du
paris-sg legends championship
et pour finir un mot de football lui en
cours se qualifie au forceps pour la
quatrième pour le 4e tour de la coupe de
france réduits à dix et malmené par les
attaquants de personnes dans le val
d'oise des saint quentinois qui évolue
comme leurs adversaires en division
excellence ont réussi à marquer au
retour des vestiaires pour l'emporter 1
à 0 on écoute les réactions
beaucoup de passes ratées
une organisation pas très correct de
notre part on y revient en deuxième mi
temps pour mettre un peu plus
d'intensité ce qu'on est chose faite qui
fait qu'au bout de dix minutes on a pu
marquer ce but justement qui n'a permis
d'avoir cette victoire il ya des choses
à rectifier on va rectifier la
possession la possession de balle où on
a on a surtout sur la première mi temps
où on a pas été tracées serein pour
garder le ballon alors qu'on a les
joueurs de qualité pour le faire et on a
mieux fait en deuxième mi temps donc je
pense que le discours dans les
vestiaires à la mi-temps est bien passé
et on les suivra car guyancourt
saint-quentin connaîtra son adversaire
demain mardi à 13 septembre le quatrième
tour se disputera le samedi 24 et le
dimanche 25 septembre c'est à présent la
fin de cette édition jour merci de nous
avoir suivis je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée et je vous retrouve
demain pour un nouveau jt